ايضا نتائج الدورات الانتخابيه الاخيره
حددت ولايه نيفادا كاحدى اهم الولايات
المتارجحه حاليا يسيطر الديمقراطيون على
نيفادا مع هيمنه على تنفيذها في مجلس
الشيوخ بعضوته في مجلس النواب ثلاثه
ديمقراطيين من نواب الولايه الاربعه كما
يحكم الولايه حاكم ديمقراطي كذلك وزير
خارجيه الولايه اي الشخص المسؤول عن تنظيم
واداره وتوثيق الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن
الجمهوريين هذا العمل يهددونا الحيمه
الديمقراطيه السباق متقارب بين مرشح
الحزبين على كل المناصب بصوره غير مسبوقه
هناك حيث يتخلف حاكم ولايه نيفادا
الديمقراطي
عن منافس الجمهوريه
المتمتع بدعم من قويه
باربع نقاط مئويه طبعا هو متفوق وفقا
استطلاع اميرسون كوليج ذهب ويقلل من نقاط
المرشح الديمقراطي كذلك غضب سكان نيفادا
ومعاناتهم من معدلات التضخم الاعلى نسبيا
في البلاد تبيعاتها من ارتفاع لاسعار
الوقود وكذلك المواد الغذائيه بالاضافه
الى اثار الاغلاق خلال جائحه كره
سبايكي
[موسيقى]
اما مقعد ولايه نيفادا في مجلس الشيوخ
فيعد افضل فرص الجمهوريين لحصد مقعد اضافي
امام لهم الاغلبيه هنا المواجهه تشمل
السيناتور الديمقراطيه كاثرين كورتيز
ماستو واسيناتور الجمهوري ادم
تشير معظم استطلاعات الراي الى نسب تاييد
متعادله تقريبا بين المرشحين رغم ان ماستو
اول سيده لاتينيه تشغل مقعدا في مجلس
الشيوخ الا ان كتله الناخبين اللاتينيين
الذين تبلغ نسبتهم نحو 30% من سكان
الولايه يميلون
للمرشح او المرشح للجمهوريه وفقا
استطلاعات الراي في وقت ايه تذهب اغلبيه
اصوات الناخبين التي لينا تقليديه الى
الديمقراطيين فان ديمقراطيين ماذا
قلقون لاسيما ان نسبه المصوتين اللاتينين
لصالح ترامب زادت منذ انتخابات 2016 الى
انتخابات 2020 بمقدار ثماني نقاط هنا هذا
هنا هذا هو الاختبار يتمثل بقدره
الديمقراطيين على تفعيل ال الدفع الناخبين
للتصويت لمواجهه الزخم الكبير الذي يمسكه
الجمهوريون